Tomas wrote to me he said David what are
your thoughts on tanki's people who
espouse apologetics for Stalin do you
think when people on the Left fond over
the most brutal dictators does that
somehow D legitimize our side of the
political spectrum so if you've not
heard the term tanky before it is a
pejorative and what it refers to is
someone who apologizes for the violence
and crimes against humanity that were
perpetrated by Marxist Leninist regimes
but most specifically in the Soviet
Union under Stalin okay when people on
the right fawn over dictators like Trump
does we rightly slam them and we
shouldn't apply a different standard to
those on the Left who do it and this
applies to Stalin this applies to Bashar
al-assad without saying that they're the
same this applies to the authoritarian
tendencies of recent and current
Venezuelan leaders as well the issue is
not so much the critique that is implied
by the word tankey but that tankey is a
pejorative and that's where you can
start to lose people because it's an ad
hominem it describes a political
position this sort of apologia for
Stalinist Russia but it is a pejorative
and it's also important to know that
there are different degrees of tanki's
like there are straight-up conspiracy
theorists who deny that Stalin was a
murderous dictator altogether and are
sort of in total fantasy land there are
others who are called tanki's and again
I try not to use the term because it you
do lose people when you use insults
there are others who aren't straight-up
conspiracy theorists who say Stalin
never did anything bad but they sort of
try to contextualise or minimize the
misdeeds of Stalin or explain that given
the circumstances in the USSR at the
time that a lot of the decisions made by
Stalin sort of made sense and that
others would have made the same
decisions where whatever degree of
apologetics for Stalinism they espouse
they slow down progress and they do hurt
the left and what you have to understand
is that with a lot of the individuals
described by the term tang
which again I think we shouldn't use
when you confront them they will say
it's not that I'm defending Stalin it's
that I'm against imperialism for example
I'm against American Empire or
colonialism or something like that but
you can be against any of those things
without apologizing for Stalin or
minimizing what Stalin did and I make no
secret out of the reality that the the
people that are described by the term
tanki even though it's not a term I use
it's not my part of the left I don't
share that much in common with them
other than the fact that I think on
social issues we would probably all be
united but on economics I think we
probably differ pretty significantly on
geopolitics I think we differ pretty
significantly and I do believe that they
hurt the left overall but my advice to
the people there are so-called tanki's
in our audience and again my advice to
the non tanki's is don't use the term
tanki because it is it is an insult I
don't even know I mean is that a term
you're familiar with pat because this is
one of those terms where in certain
circles it's become a big thing but a
lot of people on the sort of mainstream
left of the u.s. aren't even aware of
this debate that's going on yet again
I'm unfamiliar with this term kind of
like with what we discussed before
non-playable characters yeah I guess I'm
just not on those subreddits you know
I'm not in the places where these terms
are used yeah and that's also why I
think we should avoid the term tanki not
only because it is a pejorative and we
want to try to avoid using at homonyms
we want to argue political positions I
also think it's a bad idea to use it
because a lot of people just don't
understand what you're talking about I
think it's much more relevant to talk
about you know I've talked about what I
call a strain of Leninism among the left
right now and it does relate to
positions on Venezuela and Syria and
Russia and taught use more precise
accurate terms that aren't perjorative
and if somebody thinks that Leninist is
pejorative then I think there's probably
a conversation to have there about what
whether words even have value or meaning
anymore because that has a much more
specific definition send me your
thoughts
if you think that the term tanky is not
an ad hominem I also want to hear from
you because I think it's pretty pretty
clear that it is we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today get access to
the bonus show by becoming a member at
WWJ impact muncom or by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show I'll speak to you then